worst images what do you think of those
I I don't know what is a blur image do
you have a description of what this is a
blur image let's Google okay I
understand it's images that look like
something else blur blur sir word I
never heard blares I think it's just
cursed blessed images that's it
cursed blessed images let's go gamers
let's go okay first one know who we say
is that the guy from Toy Story yeah oh
my god Toy Story 2 wait is he the guy
who fixes the toy yeah he's gotta look
at woody he's got a lunchbox
I don't know I'll make her sad cringe
sad to cringe everybody my brothers TV
messed up and this happened
oh that episode of what a blurred image
that boy ain't right I don't believe
this I believe fakery is happening on
this one oh alright
ok let me know in the comments guys you
think this is fake smash like if you
think fake smash like if you don't think
fake bars no you don't have to do this
work Center has been accident-free says
Jolie who's who's Joe your mama
I heard the fun get louder who's Joe Joe
taro coos oh it's my best anime Dee I've
watched three episodes of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure basically a thing I'm
basically an intellectual at this point
basically but wait I don't understand
this image worst images wait what's on
his eyes it's security cameras Oh
Marc's watching you oh that makes sense
so epic oh you get the epic Zook I kind
of want to suck on suck sighs you only
get that big joke that thick soaked oh
wait wait they're two cameras so close
to each other right next to each other
yeah that that makes it a bit confusing
maybe one is looking left and once again
right so you can stop you know he's like
Quasimodo no I love Quasimodo's my
favorite Disney movie I like how we live
like 15 minutes apart but still we're
doing this is easier I don't want to be
in your smell that's right the Bible
read in a condescending voice by a 14
year old I want to hear that right now
Google that I know this is fake oh my
god is real yes I was like hey it sounds
like the other avocados go to toast it
turned from Batman into just like think
we need a mixer that yeah get on that
right now some metal base Peter was in
town the other day
protesting abuse of animals and handing
out stickers I gave one to my cat
I'm an [ __ ] wearing furs a choice cat
take it off right now
how dare you I'm gonna throw blood at
that cat I like it that's the solution
to people wearing fur is to throw blood
at them something used to do that's a
Burlington Coat Factory let's ruin all
of them instead yeah
worst images okay my son wanted cold
hard cash for his birthday
oh wow pretty cool you still get the
money it's still legal tender just get a
hairdryer dude oh the comments funnier
than the actual picture no baby on board
feel free to drive into me Oh
one time I nudged a car like a baby
kissed it asleep it was like and the
woman left the car in the middle of a
traffic it's like I have a baby on boy
oh my god Jesus Christ dude so you're
yeah is it you you're the baby boy oh
you do yeah that's the epic comeback
that you think about like ten hours
later you like damn it she's the baby
you'll be in there made of public
situation and just hates you stamina
yeah you're in the middle of dinner with
Marcia and it's like yeah I'm so glad
that we're doing this oh my god she's
the baby sir what do you want for your
stop make a video right now large images
blur image this is a okay I might cover
right now you can't see you but this is
a blur stupa Nana okay
it's a floppy banana - rubber banana
tink tickle tickle tickle
hey there one of those squeezy ones yeah
you want a stretchy squeezy banana they
feel really good yeah they do it that's
why I bought it we were in this store it
was actually buying the bag for your
birthday gift we're up to checkout and
it was like I I need this I just put it
on the counter I like this piece I am
trying
dude have you seen this you know what
this so you gifted yourself while
gifting me thank you yeah it was my
birthday too
I think the gift I got myself is better
than what we got you the Pope came to my
school and I caught him looking at me
Matt oh that's fake you know what I okay
I can one of this I have cardboard
cutouts hold its beauty wow
you guys know PewDiePie you like
PewDiePie do you remember 2016 PewDiePie
this is him now yeah when I talk to like
5 Danny DeVito's ok cool double demonic
taxation that's how that works
yeah more PewDiePie is the more money
you get lovebirds ripeness chart on
right that's an avocado that's not a
bird almost right in ready to eat
getting mushy oh I'm getting mushy and
the bird is on top and the bird must be
like nonny nonny nonny maji maji daya by
oh my god Christ score that's what I see
in my nightmares I was gonna say I like
how he's doing the exact same face yeah
exactly and it looks like the guy behind
istic face nobody else is a problem with
it but it's a lot of like hates people
at basketball games and you get to sit
so close right yeah I can't remember the
other one they had where they were just
like yell when they were about to score
surely that's illegal
surely you're not allowed do that that's
illegal wait write that down
jacques rousseau oh my they look so
happy about it too
if I were shaking hands at my
tinky-winky I'd be much happier than
that that's how we should greet each
other from now on
yeah we'll add this shailen every time
oh that's good
hey remember when sticking your finger
through your pants was like peak comedy
yeah now it's sexual harassment oh oh
did they do that
dad where's mom man say
his threat to blow up a bathroom had
nothing to do to the bottom dude I just
really had to go only real gamers
understand yeah when you when you have
to blow up a bathroom real hard my face
when I'm ready to nuke this bathroom
arrest him we have the paper how do you
find these things so fast you're such a
meme er I'm such a meme er when the
world might lady asked why I needed so
much antifreeze apparently fruit punch
for trick-or-treaters was not the
correct
oh my god yeah joke about that's too
funny that is also true yeah Larry's
ideas learn thank you
your name here can't be waiting my fire
only Josh that's really funny
you know when we upload videos and
everyone's like man your comedy so stale
and then thousand times like okay I
guess this is what you want
that's so funny yeah it's not even
flourished this is a Boomer subreddit
that we stumbled into by accident does
that mean we're not boomers well you're
a boomer I'm not 30 yet I have like four
months to go and this will be hilarious
I can't wait to put on my glasses and
look at this really far away on my phone
and laughs hysterically edit and share
on your Facebook wall yeah do Karen you
got a look at this on the poker chips or
slices of banana you know when you're
playing poker and the poker chips are
actually pieces of your hand yeah it's
also a terrible [ __ ] hand actually
it's a metaphor how gambling takes a
part of you Wow
what game are they playing go fish like
that's a terrible hand in any game of
carrots now way for the people in the
credit and their comments me like well
actually if you're playing gin rummy
this is an amazing hand because if you
really if they seven of speeds then you
will have wound a game of life that
needs to be a subreddit called well
actually what people can just shut up
yeah this is the best this subreddit has
to offer
okay that's players that's pretty good
Fredi game okay you win you win this
brand that's my face when I see a cow
when I was a kid I refuse to drink milk
from other countries that's a sentence
when we go to Norway I'm like I'm not
drinking this it's weird
it's a different brand I don't know this
isn't Norwegian cows yeah I was so sure
it tasted different giving them syringes
their insulin bill is so big but she
gave them insulin so they don't have to
pay for that subverted my expectations
that's still really bad I'll take the
candy please
did he ever trick-or-treating and I
related yeah I did until I was like 7 or
8 I think we never went out and actually
did it properly we just did it for the
sweets so we just put like a black
garbage bag over me and cut holes in it
and then what achievement which hat I
was like look I'm a witch give me sweets
you want to egg your house did you get
straight no we didn't do it you don't
really do it in Sweden I'm sure
someone's gonna be actually we do well
not in my age in my neighborhood we
didn't do it and maybe these days cuz
the Internet has spread stuff everywhere
we didn't have internet we would go out
and no one would have candy so they just
like gave you money basically and oh
that was the best really there was
always the one house there was always
the houses that like give you nuts and
stuff I'm like oh cool
I guess I'm spit in the face it's like
you just pissed in my bag just just give
me the nuts just say you have no rights
wait wait that reminds me I saw this
this is a blessed image what a bag of
sprite take one bag of sprite here you
go oh my sprite in bags the bags milk
all right since this subreddit sucks I'm
just gonna show you blurred images I
save there you go here's cinder block
getting there first treadmill treatment
to help lose weight
that that's a smart CAD
he's like I'm doing it right you believe
me right my food now oh that poor cat
yeah I feel bad they're like putting in
this pool but it's also very funny you
can do a cat I believe in you get that
education bro okay man watching them got
it okay he's he's he looks like he's
about to kill her that's where I'm going
he takes out the guard he's gonna
shooting him to save her okay keeps
going what is she real I don't know
what's happening oh this one is great
this is so much better than this uh
Brenda you should make your own
subreddit called better blurs better
blares he's injecting himself mm-hmm it
looks like PewDiePie
dark hair yeah okay you want some you
want drugs he did he took speed look I
know I'd rather take a child instead
[Laughter]
what are these who makes these sir one
Cornelia oh I think I've seen some of
their stuff yeah the art side looks
familiar that's good I like that
I like these way more than the subreddit
okay Reese's oh it's like that meme
where they look at at the guy help you
know that's your reason to live now it
actually takes a really high IQ to
understand these means some of these are
very obscure I remember my POV giving my
dog belly rubs good I like that one that
was my face when you did that oh this is
good
they're good again I can confirm this is
accurate oh my god I would be so pissed
if my graphics card arrived with that in
it it's just actually a Face Swap that
is Snorlax his face on his can somebody
safe edit the face swap on it do it now
yeah do it Sam prior tender wanted okay
poppy banana victory on this one that
was good I like that
good job have you seen this one oh I
have this is one that's a pillow oh it's
so freaky it has four eyes oh that's
that's definitely gonna get me that's
gonna kill me in my dreams
thank you jack for joining me on this
amazing subreddit we should turn into
something completely different that's
what we do
no problem I'm glad that we can look at
some blur images together all of us
already are awful and you should feel
bad for yourselves yeah
never up both again hey Dora hey though
yes yes no yes yes well you haven't
tried to pursue me later today after 50
million approached by etch down just
down it's still relevant just download
it